Você já imaginou que um simples
aminoácido poderia literalmente
reprogramar suas células e reverter o
relógio biológico? Não estou falando de
promessa milagrosa ou daquelas modas
passageiras de internet. Estou falando
de ciência pesada publicada na Science,
uma das revistas mais respeitadas do
planeta. Pesquisadores descobriram algo
que a indústria farmacêutica prefere que
você não saiba. A taurina, esse composto
que todo mundo acha que é só ingrediente
de energético, pode ser a chave para
aumentar a sua expectativa de vida e
rejuvenescer suas células no nível mais
profundo. Estudos recentes em 2023 e 25
estão mostrando resultados que deixariam
qualquer remédio de farmácia no chinelo.
E olha, não é exagero não. Os dados são
tão impressionantes que vão te fazer
questionar por que seu médico nunca te
contou isso? Então, se você quer
entender como algo tão acessível e
barato pode fazer tanta diferença na sua
saúde, fica comigo até o final. Por que
que eu vou te mostrar aqui pode mudar
completamente a forma como você enxerga
o envelhecimento. Deixa te contar uma
história real.
Em 2023, um time internacional de
cientistas liderados pela Universidade
de Colúmbia publicou na Science um
estudo que virou o jogo completamente.
Eles descobriram que conforme
envelhecemos, os níveis de taurina no
nosso sangue despencam. E não é pouca
coisa não. Nos camundongos a queda foi
brutal. Nos macacos a mesma coisa. E nos
humanos adivinha? Exatamente o mesmo
padrão. Mas aqui vem o pulo do gato.
Quando eles reverteram essa deficiência
através de suplementação, os resultados
foram de arrepiar. Os vermes viveram de
10 a 23% mais tempo e os camundongos
entre 10 e 12% a mais de vida. E não
estou falando só de viver mais, estou
falando de viver melhor, com qualidade,
com células, funcionando como se fossem
jovens de novo. Agora você deve estar se
perguntando, mas como diabos um
aminoácido consegue fazer isso? A
resposta tá no que acontece dentro das
suas células. Eu vou te explicar de um
jeito simples. A taurina age em cinco
frentes poderosas que são exatamente os
mesmos mecanismos que a medicina
convencional ignora. Primeiro, ela freia
a cenessência celular. Sabe aquelas
células que ficam velhas, mas se recusam
a morrer e ficam lá atrapalhando tudo? A
taurina limpa essa bagunça. Segundo, ela
protege os telômeros. Pensa nos
telômeros como as pontinhas de plástico
do cadastro do seu tênis. Quando eles
encurtam demais, a célula para de
funcionar direito. A taurina mantém eles
inteiros. Terceiro, isso aqui é crucial,
ela turbina as suas mitocôndrias. As
mitocôndrias são as usinas de energia
das células. Quando elas falham, você
envelhece rápido. A taurina faz elas
funcionarem como novas. Mas não para por
aí. Quarto ponto, a taurina reduz o dano
do DNA. Toda vez que suas células se
dividem, existe um risco de erro. Com o
tempo, esses erros se acumulam. A
taurina age como um escudo protetor,
diminuindo esses danos. E quinto, talvez
o mais importante de todos, ela combate
a inflamação crônica. Sabe aquela
inflamação silenciosa que ninguém vê,
mas que está te correndo por dentro? Os
cientistas chamam isso de inflamagem,
que é inflamação do envelhecimento.
A taurina atua diretamente nesse
processo, reduzindo os marcadores
inflamatórios do sangue. Agora vamos
falar de dosagem, porque isso é onde a
maioria das pessoas erra. Os estudos e
humanos usaram doses que variaram de 500
mg até 6 g por dia. Mas aqui entre nós,
baseado na literatura científica mais
recente de 20242, a dose que aparece com
mais frequência como efetiva e segura é
de 1000 mg por dia, ou seja, 1 g.
Simples assim. E olha que interessante,
essa dose foi testada em múltiplos
estudos, mostrando benefícios
cardiovasculares, metabólicos e
cognitivos. Um estudo publicado em 2024
mostrou que 1000 mg por dia durante 12
semanas seduziu pressão arterial,
melhorou o perfil lipídico e até
diminuiu a glicemia de jejum. Outro
estudo no mesmo ano demonstrou melhora
na função cardíaca e aumentou a fração
de ejeção do ventrículo esquerdo. Mas
tem um detalhe importante que você
precisa saber. A taurina que você ingere
na dieta não é suficiente para reverter
a deficiência de envelhecimento. Mesmo
se você comer carne, peixe, frutos do
mar todos os dias, a quantidade que você
consegue através da alimentação não
chega nem perto do que você precisa para
ter efeito terapêutico. Por isso,
suplementação faz toda a diferença. E
veganos e vegetarianos, aí a situação é
mais crítica. A taurina vem quase
exclusivamente de fontes animais. Quem
segue uma dieta plant based está
praticamente garantindo uma deficiência
severa de taurina ao longo dos anos. E
tem mais uma coisa que os estudos
mostraram que é ouro puro. Exercício
físico aumenta os níveis de taurina
naturalmente. Um estudo de 2023
demonstrou que após exercício aeróbico
intenso, os livros de taurina no sangue
sobem significativamente. Ou seja,
quando você combina suplementação com a
atividade física, você potencializa os
efeitos. é a abordagem integrativa
perfeita, nutrição adequada,
suplementação estratégica, estilo de
vida ativo. Não é à toa que as
populações que consomem mais taurina
através da dieta, como japoneses e
coreanos, que comem muito peixe, frutos
do mar, tem menor incidência de doenças
cardiovasculares e maior longividade.
Agora, sobre segurança, a taurina é um
dos suplementos mais seguros que
existem. Estudos mostram que doses de
até 3 g por dia são completamente
seguras a longo prazo, não tem efeito
colateral significativo, não interfere
com medicamentos, é barato, acessível e
você encontra em qualquer loja de
suplementos. Mas claro, a medicina
convencional não vai te falar disso. E
sabe por quê? Porque não dá para
patentear. É o meninoácido natural. Não
tem como a indústria farmacêutica
transformar isso numa pílula cara e
lucrar bilhões. Então, simplesmente
ignoram. deixam você envelhecer,
desenvolver essas crônicas para depois
te encher de remédios caros que tratam
sintomas, mas nunca a causa raiz. Então,
olha o que você precisa fazer. Comece
que 1 g de taurina por dia, ou seja,
1000 mg. Pode ser em cápsula, pode ser
em pó misturado na água, tanto faz.
Importante é a consistência. Tome todos
os dias, de preferência junto com uma
refeição. Combine isso com exercício
regular, especialmente exercício
aeróbico. Mantenha uma alimentação rica
em proteínas animais de qualidade se
você não for vegano. E se for, a
suplementação não é opcional, é
obrigatória. Faça isso por pelo menos 3
meses e observe. Você vai sentir mais
energia, mais clareza mental, melhor
recuperação muscular, mas o efeito mais
profundo está acontecendo de você não
vê. Nas suas células, nas suas
mitocôndrias, no seu DNA. É ali que a
mágica está acontecendo.
Saia do vídeo agora se você gosta de
ficar superficial. Eu vou te contar uma
verdade conveniente. O YouTube e o
Conselho de Medicina me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, censurar
dosagenses, omitir protocolos
controversos. Na comunidade fechada não
existe esse filtro. Compartilho os
exatos protocolos que eu uso na minha
clínica. Casos de reversão que parecem
possíveis, combinações of label que
funcionam, fornecedores confiáveis,
interpretação avançada de exames. É
basicamente ter acesso ao meu cérebro
médico sem intermediários. Temos lives
semanais respondendo perguntas, PDF
exclusive com 47 protocolos, grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer a visão funcional
real, sem simplificação para as massas,
clique em seja membro. E não é para
curiosos, é para quem quer resultados.
Agora, se você quer ir ainda mais fundo,
existe o nível dois. A cada duas semanas
nós fazemos live de imersão total, 2
horas de duração, desse artigos
científicos, linha por linha, debatendo
controvérsias que ninguém ousa tocar,
revelando os bastidores das pesquisas
que a indústria não quer que você
entenda. E tem mais, seu nome será
mencionado nos vídeos como
agradecimento. Você se torna a parte
visível dessa comunidade de elite que
está reescrevendo as regras da medicina.
Enquanto a maioria assiste passivamente,
você estará ao meu lado construindo
conhecimento de verdade, tendo o seu
reconhecimento público como alguém que
investe no que realmente importa. Não é
só sobre aprender, é sobre pertencer ao
ciclo interno de quem está mudando o
jogo. Poucos têm a coragem. Você tem?
Agradecimentos especiais aos nossos
membros queridos dos estudos avançados
da comunidade fechada no YouTube. José
Fortunato Marinho, Fernando Machado, Sou
Juciuli, Cristina Carol, Romana Moraril,
Estela Mares, Eloterapias Integrativas,
Saúde e Antes da Doença. Eu agradeço o
coração pelo apoio prestado.